loneliness all of us in this room will
experience loneliness at some point in
our lives loneliness is not a function
of being alone but rather a function of
how socially connected you are to those
around you there could be somebody in
this room right now
surrounded by a thousand people
experiencing loneliness and while
loneliness can be attributed many things
as an architect I'm gonna tell you say
how loneliness can be the result of our
built environment the very homes we
choose to live in let's take a look at
this house it's a nice house there's a
big yard to get fence two-car garage and
the home might be in a neighborhood like
this and for many people around the
globe this home this neighborhood it's a
dream and yet the danger of achieving
the stream is a false sense of
connection and an increase in social
isolation I know I can hear you now
there's somebody in the room screaming
at me inside their head that's my house
and that's my neighborhood and I know
everyone on my block to which I would
answer terrific and I wish there were
more people like you because I'd wager
to guess there's more people in the room
living in a similar situation that might
not know their neighbors they might
recognize them and say hello but under
their breath they're asking their spouse
what was your name again
so they can ask the question by name to
signify they know them social media also
contributes this small sense of
connection this image is probably all
too familiar you're standing in the
elevator sitting in a cafe and you look
around and everyone's on their phone
you're not texting or face checking
facebook but everyone else is and maybe
like me you've been in a situation where
you've made eye contact smiles and said
hello and then have a person
their earbud and say I'm sorry what did
you say I find this incredibly isolating
the concept I'd like to share with you
today is an antidote to isolation it's
not a new concept in fact it's an
age-old way of living and it still
exists in many non-european cultures
around the world and about 50 years ago
the Danes decided to make up a new name
and since then tens of thousands of
Danish people have been living in this
connected way and it's being pursued
more widely around the globe as people
are seeking community
this concept is cohousing cohousing is
an intentional neighborhood where people
know each other and look after one
another in cohousing you have your own
home but you also share significant
spaces both indoors and out but before I
show you some pictures of cohousing I'd
like to first introduce you to my
friends she went in Spencer when I met
first met Sheila in spencer's they were
just entering their 60s and Spencer was
looking ahead at the end of a long
career in elementary education I really
disliked the idea that he might not have
children in his life upon retirement
there now my neighbors we live in the
cohousing communities that I not only
designed but developed and have my
architecture practice in this community
is very intentional about our social
interactions so let me take you on the
tour from the outside we look like any
other small apartment building in fact
we look identical to the one next door
except that we're bright yellow inside
the homes are fairly conventional we all
have living rooms and kitchens bedrooms
and baths in there nine of these homes
around the central courtyard this limp
line and this one Center in Sheila's and
the thing that makes this building
uniquely cohousing are not the homes but
rather what happens here the social
interactions that happen in around that
central courtyard when I live across the
courtyard I look forward to seeing
Spencer and Sheila in fact every morning
this is what I see
spencer waving at me furiously as we're
making our breakfast from our homes we
look down into the courtyard and
depending on the time of year we see
this kids and grownups in various
combinations playing and hanging out
with each other there's a lot of
giggling and chatter there's a lot of
hula hooping and every now and then hey
quit hitting me or cry from one of the
kids these are the sounds of our daily
lives and the sounds of social
connectedness at the bottom of the
courtyard there set of double doors and
both lead into the common house and I
consider the common house the secret
sauce of cohousing it's a secret sauce
because it's the place where the social
interactions and community life begin
and from there it radiates out through
the rest of the community inside our
common house we have a large dining room
to see all 28 of us and our guests and
we dine together three times a week
in support of those meals we have a
large kitchen so that we can take turns
cooking for each other in teams of three
so that means with 17 adults I lead cook
once every six weeks two other times I
show up and help my team with the
preparation and cleanup and all those
other nights I just show up I have
dinner talk with my neighbors
and I go home having been fed a
delicious meal by someone who cares
about my vegetarian preferences our nine
families have intentionally chosen an
alternative way of living instead of
pursuing the American dream
where we might have been isolated in our
single-family homes we instead chose Co
housing so that we can increase our
social connections and that's how Co
housing starts with a shared intention
to live collaboratively an intention is
a single most important characteristic
that differentiates cohousing from any
other housing model and while intention
is difficult to see or even show I'm an
architect and I can't help but show you
more pictures so here are a few examples
to illustrate how
tension has been expressed in some of
the communities I visited through the
careful selection of furniture lighting
and acoustic materials to support eating
skeleton the careful location and visual
access to kids player areas around and
inside the common house and the
consideration of scale and distribution
of social gathering nodes in and around
the community to support our daily lives
all of these spaces help contribute to
and elevate the sense of community in
each community what was that word
communitas communitas is a fancy social
science way of saying spirit of
community and in visiting over 80
different communities my measure of
communitas became how frequently did
residents eat together while it's
completely up to each group how
frequently they have common meals I know
some that have eaten together every
single night for the past 40 years I
know others that have an occasional
potluck once or twice a month and for my
observations I can tell you those that
eat together more frequently they
exhibit higher levels of communitas it
turns out when you eat together you
start planning more activities together
when you eat together you share more
things you start to watch each other's
kids you lend out your power tools you
borrow each other's cars and despite all
this my daughter loves to say everything
is not rainbows and unicorns in
cohousing
and I'm not best friends with every
single person in my community we even
have differences in conflicts but living
in cohousing were intentional about our
relationships
we're motivated to resolve our
differences we follow up we check in we
speak our personal truths and when
appropriate we apologize skeptics will
say that cohousing is only interesting
or attractive to a very small group of
people
and I agree with that if you look at
Western cultures around the globe those
living in cohousing
are just a fractional percent but that
needs to change because our very lives
depend upon it in 2015 Brigham Young
University completed a study that showed
a significant increased risk of
premature deaths in those who are living
in isolation the US Surgeon General has
declared isolation to be a public health
epidemic and this epidemic is not
restricted to youth the US alone so when
I said earlier that colorizing is an
antidote to isolation what I should have
said is that cohousing
can save your life if I was a doctor I
would tell you to take two aspirin and
call me in the morning but as an
architect I'm going to suggest that you
take a walk with your neighbor share a
meal together and call me in 20 years
thank you
[Applause]